united is gearing up for spring break we
are expecting
for long lines expect for it to be a
little bit tougher to find a parking
space so you're definitely going to want
to make sure to plan ahead
well a lot of the country isn't as lucky
as we are here with the warm weather uh
is that one of the biggest straws to las
vegas for spring break
yeah i think so people are eager to get
out they're looking for a little bit of
sun looking for a little bit of fun and
i think a destination like vegas is
something that candidly a lot of people
didn't get the opportunity to enjoy the
last couple of years you know with
social distancing and all the pandemic
protocols definitely people are looking
to take vacations that were more around
social distancing being individual being
outside whereas you know a place like
vegas and the crowds and the shows i
think people are really excited just to
get back out there and experience all of
the things that vegas has to offer
there are also a lot of travelers
looking to escape las vegas for some new
sites uh where do you see those
travelers going to from las vegas
yeah from las vegas we're seeing a lot
of people looking to get a little bit of
that uh sunshine but a little bit of
water next to it so looking for a lot of
those beach destinations places in
florida have been very popular uh also
seeing a little bit of interest in
mountain destination so people looking
to take advantage of those last few
weeks of ski season going up to colorado
to wyoming out to california just to
take advantage of a little bit of fresh
powder um also we actually did a
consumer survey and found that more than
70 percent of travelers surveyed found
that they were thinking about going
somewhere they've never been before this
year and a little more than 30 percent
had considered taking an extra splurge
to really go above and beyond on a trip
this year so i think some people might
be even thinking about
charting out and trying someplace that
they've never experienced and trying
something totally different
you mentioned the pandemic there
there's been a pretty long period here
where
a whole new customer base has come into
uh the airlines but haven't had the
opportunity to fly
what would you recommend to people who
are going to the airport for the first
time ever
well if you're going to the airport for
the first time ever i think again making
sure you're planning ahead is really key
so you're going to want to get to the
airport at least two hours in advance
for a domestic flight three for
something that's international just to
make sure that you have all the time you
need to check your bags to go through
security to find your gates maybe grab a
bite to eat just to get settled in and
comfortable we're also recommending to
make sure that customers download the
united app before you go there are so
many things that you can do in advance
before you even get to the airport to
save time so you can check your bag in
advance you can
see any sort of coveted restrictions or
protocols that might still be in place
that you have to abide by or follow and
we'll have all the information for you
right at your fingertips to make sure to
get you prepared
okay you mentioned that united is flying
more than 3 800 flights per day on
average during the spring break period
how does that rate compare to before the
pandemic
weird i'd say from a flight's
perspective we are just shy of where we
were in 2019 uh but we're pretty close i
think from a traveler's perspective it's
not going to really look much different
to you than those crowds that had spring
break in 2019 so you know while we're
still a little bit behind where we were
uh before the pandemic uh demand is
coming back people are eager to travel
business travel is coming back so we're
just really excited to see people
traveling again and i know that our
frontline employees are eager to welcome
everyone back on board